vous avez tourné combien de temps avec
peut-être 12 ans je sais pas
très bien
de très à l'écoute qui adoré les
discussions
philosophiques psychologie il aimait
s'intéresser dans les petits cancans
dans les petites histoires c'est
quelqu'un qui a oui qui adore parler qui
adore qui est très humain c'est
quelqu'un de réagi on a prononce à
disparition parce que pour vous c'est
quelqu'un qui est voilà et qui on a
travaillé pendant 12 ans ça va réagi
comment on réagit pas c'est le temps qui
fait
qu'on
qu'on est perdu en fait parce que c'est
l'absence c'est le silence c'est
l'inconnu
bien sûr on pense à la victime mais on
pense à sa famille surtout
on respecte leur silence aussi et nous
c'est pas une réaction brutale comme si
on apprenait quelque chose là c'est
lancinant c'est on attend on sait pas
est-ce qu'il allait bien
alors moi je l'avais pas eu récemment
parce que et comme dit Nathalie il avait
que des bonnes nouvelles
professionnelles ça nous en tant
qu'acteurs
il était très dans le cou quoi et quand
on est artiste et qu'on aime notre
métier ça ça contribue énormément à
notre moral ça booste toi tu le connais
c'est bien est-ce que ça lui ressemble
de disparaître des radars comme ça
on peut pas savoir ça on connaît pas les
gens à ce point-là mais quand il dit
c'est quelqu'un de très sensible de 13
ans
et Marie la même chose que Palmade si
demain je renverse quelqu'un je lui ai
dit je me fondre
que tu moi je suis jamais allée dans ce
genre de discussion avec lui moi je l'ai
toujours en été plutôt sur des
discussions
moi c'était vacances ouais mais nous
c'était plutôt le travail les amours la
vie on n'a jamais parlé de drame comme
ça TOI tu as tenté de le joindre non bah
non ça sert à quoi parce qu'on sait très
bien que il va pas répondre
les choses comme on les acteurs de Plus
belle la vie
mais en fait personne en fait on n'a pas
il n'y a pas de réaction c'est on attend
j'y croyais vous croyez encore qu'on va
le retrouver et le temps c'est horrible
le temps il est nul là le temps
le temps et on l'aime pas ce temps-là
vous n'êtes pas réuni avec tous les
acteurs qui est avec lui pour dire voilà
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire ou
qu'est-ce non pas du tout et on peut
personne
non
vous attendez quoi oui il y a un peu de
sidération parmi parmi vous je crois
c'est à dire que tout le monde est très
étonné mais vous qui le connaissez bien
Fabienne est-ce que la fuite la cavale
comme ça dans la nature la disparition
lui qui était très famille famille
privée famille professionnelle aussi
famille d'acteurs est-ce que ça ça peut
lui ressembler
prendre la fuite comme ça disparaître
j'ai envie de dire non mais j'en sais
rien on des fois on connaît même pas
son propre mari ou sa propre femme on
sait jamais on n'est pas à l'intérieur
des gens on n'est pas avec leur
blessures on n'est pas avec leur passé
pour savoir même nous on se connaît pas
vraiment devant une situation difficile
dramatique personne c'est vraiment
comment il va réagir
tant qu'on n'est pas face au drame on se
connaît même pas soi-même en vrai donc
moi je peux pas me prononcer alors il y
a beaucoup de gens qui disent aussi que
il a vécu un drame il y a 10 ans avec
l'assassinat de son frère terrible aux
Etats-Unis les jeunes partent par balle
d'une violence inouïe en 2013 donc là on
est 10 ans après donc voilà il avait si
je puis dire digérer ça on en parlant et
en parler beaucoup d'en parler
énormément non mais au sens où il
essayait si vous voulez en en parlant de
sortir ce qu'il avait envie peut-être
d'ailleurs vous en a-t-il parlé
énormément oui parce que bah il me dit
ça j'ai dû pour toi aussi pour pour
Jean-Pierre justement et il savait que
je croyais aux âmes et tout ça et il me
fait tu sais moi j'y crois énormément je
sais que mon frère est toujours à côté
de moi et c'est vrai que ça allait être
traumatisé que c'est son absence de son
frère c'est très très dur sans faire qui
a disparu il y a 10 ans un artiste
remarquable hein aux États-Unis qui a
d'ailleurs une place à Paris à son nom
aujourd'hui et voilà ça a été un drame
familial évidemment horrible d'ailleurs
la dernière il était assez actif sur les
réseaux sociaux et la dernière vidéo
enfin photo qu'il a postée pardon c'est
une photo de son frère quelques jours
avant sa disparition donc c'était
quelque chose qui est des proches disent
que ils ne peuvent pas croire qu'il
aurait qui se serait volatilisé par
rapport à ses parents ne pas donner de
nouvelles à ses parents c'est que ça lui
en sont tellement pas qu'ils n'arrivent
pas à croire à cette thèse certains
proches que j'ai donc j'ai vu des propos
alors l'arrêt de la série aussi pareil
que la nuit dans un état compliqué
mais là il avait une bonne nouvelle
parce que la série allait certainement
pas le tournage mi-octobre vous allez
c'est ça tournage mi-octobre voilà il
avait un rôle très important très
important voilà c'était écrit à la fin à
l'arrêt là il était si je puis dire
magnifique par un personnage en
évolution donc on lui réservait un rôle
majeur dans la série et c'est vrai que
pour lui c'était professionnelment
l'apogée de reprendre la série donc
c'est ça aussi qui fait dire enfin qui
fait penser à la famille qui ne serait
pas partie de son plein Grégoire
il y a eu peut-être bien sûr cet
événement bien sûr que cette jeune fille
qui a été renversée et de ce que vient
de nous dire Nathalie c'est vrai que
c'est incroyable qu'il ait dit ça c'est
toujours avant qui vous est dit moi si
demain je renverse quelqu'un je fonère
le témoignage de Nathalie est
extrêmement important ici ce soir et va
effectivement
ouvrir l'enquête sous un jour nouveau
c'est à dire que c'est plus le
coïncidence là presque prémonitoire je
dirais c'est presque prémonitoire donc
les les enquêteurs très intéressés mais
la jeune fille elle est elle est en vie
elle a fait de nombreux appels elle lui
a dit voilà elle lui a dit voilà
lui a laissé des mots des lettres la
question qu'on se pose tous c'est est-ce
qu'il va prendre une décision tout de
suite et se dire voilà c'est trop lourd
pour moi je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
et je je savoir les comédies réparables
c'est ça
peut-être je sais pas d'où il sortait
peut-être qu'il avait pris juste un
petit verre d'alcool donc il a eu peur
qu'on qu'on achète il pouvait pas savoir
si la dame était décédée ou pas et je
pense que à ce moment-là il a dû dans un
état lui qui est tellement famille
tellement
entier que ça dû lui faire un mal
terrible de renverser cette personne
donc après je voilà je pense je sais pas
ce qui ajoute au mystère c'est la carte
bleue le lendemain le théâtre plusieurs
heures après et le téléphone qui marche
encore donc donc ça veut dire que on ne
sait pas ce qui s'est passé mais il n'a
pas pris une décision immédiate brutale
le lendemain encore et c'est lui qui
utilisait sa carte bleue on sait pas
parce que vu que c'est dans une
boulangerie qui s'est fait voler sa
carte ça peut être sur un distributeur
j'aurais dit ok faut le code là c'est
une boulangerie tu l'apprécié c'est
possible c'est le téléphone qui
fonctionne aussi moi je pense que le
téléphone fonctionnait la carte aussi
voilà je pense qu'il l'avait encore
voilà je pense que c'est je pense que
c'était lui le 4 et le 5 terminé
quatre après plus de son plus d'image
volatiliser donc s'il a pris une
décision entre guillemets radicale dans
le sens de ce qui vous le disait c'était
après quelques heures ce qui ce qui ce
qui est aussi va intriguer les
enquêteurs ça est-ce qu'il a réfléchi
est-ce qu'il a pris conscience voilà le
mystère c'est encore épaissi aujourd'hui
avec cette enquête pour disparition
inquiétante Fabienne on sait pas voilà
on espère qu'on va le retrouver on
espère bien sûr et qu'il est vivant
qu'est-ce que vous lui diriez ce soir
pour inciter peut-être s'il y a encore
vivant à voilà à revenir et à redonner
le signe de vie il faut qu'il revienne
déjà pour ces pour ses parents qui ont
déjà perdu un fils donc
et pour pour tous ces amis
malheureusement c'est un accident
fâcheux mais heureusement elle n'est pas
décédée
oui bien sûr
ce qui s'est passé voilà exactement et
oui parce que vous voulez juste
comprendre qui s'était passé
je te sens
après lui dire qu'il y a rien de plus
important que que la vie j'ai envie de
dire mais ça veut rien dire ce que je
dis donc ça sert à rien c'est normal
c'est compliqué pour toi c'est quelqu'un
qui attendait pendant 12 ans et on
comprend que tu sois tu sois extrêmement
ému un site Natalie en tout cas ton
témoignage Nathalie était incroyable
soit parce que c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment c'est fou
que vous ayez parlé de ça c'est
incroyable
en tout cas on espère voilà on pense à
sa famille on espère qu'il y a peu de
drame il a pas pris de décision
irréversible bien sûr merci en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous merci Nathalie et
merci Fabienne merci à tous
[Applaudissements]